monde est attaché à mon péché
nouvelle journée de baptême de l'air
pour les enfants en difficulté à
l'aérodrome de saint cyr l'école
l'association fly heynckes avait
convoqué une trentaine de jeunes
défavorisés sourou hospitalisé au
programme construction d'avions en bois
et vol au dessus du château de
versailles
parmi la dizaine de pilotes bénévoles
présents ce jour là
manon altazin 22 ans sourd de naissance
genevois me souviens de 20 ans
il fait un couteau
à vous élever
allez
c'est suite à un baptême de l'air qu'on
lui avait offert quand elle avait 16 ans
que manon altazin a décidé de relever le
défi apprendre à piloter
malgré sa surdité la revue à la baisse
ce droit est un peu vous en tant que
souris vendanges tout avoir par rapport
d'abord on a les capacités de travail
aux bisons
très entouré dans son aéro club des
mureaux qui compte d'autres pilotes
handicapés
la jeune élève est souvent confronté à
l'incompréhension des gens elle en a
fait une motivation supplémentaire
les forts vents
ou pas
21 tout ça m'a touché enfin ma femme a
trouvé que c'est pas parce que ton a
monté top on déguste mentor là bas peut
pas par un jour pour compteurs avec
notre corps torben nous qu'on pense ou
encore parlent parfois avantageux
aujourd'hui il existe plusieurs aéro
clubs dont celui des mureaux qui font la
promotion de l'aviation pour les
personnes handicapées moteur mais la loi
française interdit aux pilotes
handicapés d'exercer une activité
professionnelle seuls quelques uns ont
pu obtenir une dérogation
d'autres ont passé leur licence aux
etats unis pays qui autorisent la
professionnalisation des pilotes privés
handicapés manon de son côté ne veut pas
en faire son métier son rêve devenir
kiné